each year an estimated 400 million
people worldwide are diagnosed with
dengue fever Bangladesh has been
reporting an alarming increase in cases
since May this year
in many hospitals they're making an
extra effort to create space for new
patients
we have made an extra Ward available to
deal with the increased number of
patients our doctors nurses and other
staff members to experienced and trained
enough to deal with Dengue patients
Dengue symptoms can be similar to the
common flu and can only be confirmed
with a blood test
many of the patients been brought to
hospitals are children
[Music]
my 12 year old
s are very high fever after blood
to Dengue positive so we had to have him
admitted thank God he's now improving
and his fever's gone down
a world Bank report released last year
found a wider link between the shifting
climate conditions here and the number
of people getting sick the increase in
Dengue cases is Raising alarm among
people in Dhaka and other places and the
doctors in many hospitals are struggling
to cope with Rising number of Patients
health authorities are preparing more
hospitals to trade Dengue patients
there is increasing pressure on the
hospitals and the number of patients
admitted is also Rising we don't want
more patients to die we have arranged
alternative facilities where we can
treat dengue patients aside from the
existing hospitals okay experts say
Dengue is gradually becoming more common
in Bangladesh the virus is transmitted
through the bite of an infected mosquito
and the Region's lower levels of
humidity at higher temperatures create
the perfect environment for mosquitoes
to breed
compared to the last two decades our
scientific analysis shows that flare-ups
of dengue virus typically took place in
the month of August and September but
this year we're seeing changes in the
pattern rising in the month of October
and this has to be due to the impacts of
climate change
Health experts say the 80s species of
mosquito which carries the virus has
already spread to most other parts of
the country aside from the capital Dhaka
and that could make the situation go
from bad to worse than with chaudry Al
Jazeera Dhaka